這是一條非常牛逼的視頻
我說的
這條視頻我會告訴你
怎麼做一整公司
怎麼做自媒體
怎麼讓自己做的變得越來越好
怎麼能把一件事做成怎麼轉到錢
我可以這麼講
我們百分之九十以上的人甚至百分之九十五的人
都已經受了
雖然我是到位要想想
但是我沒想到明白我這個時候該怎麼講
因為今天內部視頻會的時候很多老伙計
其實問題都和這個想問
所以我決定馬上派這麼一條視頻
我也沒想好怎麼講但是
講到哪兒說哪兒
我可以保證他非常有價值
另外以後你會的我好原來是這麼回事
就這麼自信
首先我說一下我們大部分的狀態為什麼說我們大部分
對這個世界的理解都是錯的
你看你現在是不是這樣一個情況
你每天把忙
忙得不得了
最後的時候
不知道忙上
做了好多項沒什麼項目是你的
每天也寫了好的東西什麼各種報告
各種PPT壓各種總結
對不對
沒有哪個內容最後多一下了
結果你會發現如果出現什麼經理下行
然後大幣你們不好啊
你還要面臨
什麼被此之啊或者將心的這麼一個情況
是不是我告訴你
是你自己活生生的
把你自己背上這個樣子
你自己就是一家公司結果你自己到處給自己找到吧
好了我不廢話了
我決定就說幾個我靈安拉了
撞他來了
我就說幾個概念我就一間間間間間間著我概念
可能也就是一分鐘兩分鐘吧
我已經把這個事情說清楚而且告訴你
具體的方法
首先第一個什麼是公司
什麼是公司
對吧我們去為什麼去買一家公司的產品
是不是因為這個公司的產品能改變你能讓你變得更好
所以你會買這家公司的產品
是這個了就吧
一個公司不能改變你不能讓你變得更好
讓你變得更差你會買到的產品嗎
不會吧
所以我們把它這句話總結為一句話
我們買一家公司的產品是因為這家公司的產品能讓我變得更好
好了如果我們要開家公司
那麼一家好公司是不是我們這家公司應該能夠讓別人變得更好
沒錯吧你是不是覺得我在廢話好最後我來數一句話
那麼當你開公司的時候
想清楚
你的公司應該能讓別人變得更好
那麼最好這家公司能讓你自己變得更好
這是第一套認知展示放的事
他很有用的
讓我們講第二個事
我們好像認為一人公司就是一個人
一個人敢一個人敢死了這個人
我告訴你錯了
也不是你們理解的
其實一個人公司不是一個人
是好幾個人我告訴你
這道理解都太副下的
那我先
放過來公司裡面是不是有幾個港位
這是
這是說應該我剛好像是
最少他是應該有產品的沒產品你賣賣賣的
第二你是被我渠到
也有營銷也可以是不代表東西賣入通過什麼渠到賣入的
第三好公司多少代表個品牌是不代表的三件事
這三件事我好多人敢贏公司好多人
是不是應該是這樣
那麼現在我就思考這麼一個問題
第一是不是理由產品什麼產品能讓人變得更好的產品
你是不是應該有營銷
你再告訴別人怎麼能讓
你變得更好
第三你是不是最好有一個品牌
你去把這個事情要講清楚
讓別人覺得
原來是這個
好回到我們剛才那個邏輯
你一個公司能讓別人變好
如果這個公司能讓我自己變好
那麼我變好的方法
也可以
讓你們變好
那麼請問
我把自己變好的方法打包上一個產品能讓你們變得更好的
是不是產品
有當然是不是這麼回事
第二
我來告訴你這個產品是怎麼能讓你們變得更好的
實施求實的跟你們降
是不是有營銷是不是就會去到
第三件事我自己就因為這個事情變得更好的
它是不是就不是平派
好現在我們再講一個問題
我現在要顧家一款產品
這個產品真的可以幫你變得更好
什麼時候做菜我不知道
大家的一年以後或者是兩年以後或者是三年以後
可能是
但是我有信心一定能做菜
那麼好的
至少去能讓我自己變得更好的
是這個邏輯吧
OK
我能不能現在就開始記錄
我是怎麼打到這個產品的
我是不是現在就給你們演示
就是演示我記錄下來我中間
那我是怎麼這個變得更好的這個過程你記錄下來
是不是我自己做的這個事情
它可能就是個品牌
我所有的事情就給你呈現出來了
那麼我問你一個問題
那麼我是不是在未來做準備
我不知道這麼講大家能體會
如果你們能體會我在解釋一下
如果一個方法能讓我變得越來越好
那麼如果這個方法抽離出來
也能讓你變得或者至少讓一部分人變得越來越好
那麼在是不是就可以是一款產品
那麼我現在記錄了所有的內容我是怎麼變得越來越好
我怎麼打磨這款產品的
我是怎麼思考的怎麼想的
是不是其實就是營銷
最後我讓自己變得越來越好是不是就是個品牌
那麼這個又回到一個點了
你怎麼保證你變得越來越好的這個方法
同樣是和於別人的
或者是你做的這個產品別人就需要
好我帶給你確定你講
人是不是都需要
健康
人是不是都要考慮財富
人是不是都要考慮幸福
人是不是都要考慮社交關係
是不是是希望大家都考慮
那麼理論人來說
我能讓我自己賺到錢
我能讓我自己變得更精靠
我能讓我自己獲得財富
我能讓我有更好社交關係的人
這個方法應該也可以適合於一部分人
是不是我不說所有人一部分人
那麼好的
現在你聽明白什麼叫一個人的如此的嗎
因為公司根本不是一個人敢所有的事
因為公司是什麼
因為公司就是我自己去做一個讓改變我自己
那麼我改變我自己的這個方法
這個方法才就是一個產品
我記錄這個方法的過程
比如說我的私媒體就是我的英雄
我把我自己變得更好的
這個過程
就是我的品牌故事